here we go the yardbird Carl yeah he
played that even in this active career
quite a bit mr. Laurent yeah this is an
interesting line it's it's supposed to
be a little bit shaky for black butt cap
it's something where white has to know
his stuff precisely and I mean I'm
playing this very quickly which might
suggest I know it but I don't I only
know when the moves up to here I think
night before as an issue here right do I
have to keep on c6 now I'm not sure all
right let's be quick M cancels long at
age 5 coming something like that i think
it's how they how they play it mmm they
thought my dark squared Bishop looks bad
anyway so maybe trade it
if he drops back I'm not unhappy the
night wants to go to a forum or
something along these lines anyway hmm I
don't know 56 I mean you can't play that
the should be six cannot be abandoned oh
ok that's interesting and ok cannot
casts a long or that easy now but all
that easily now but I don't know how
important this is really is I can
already do stuff here so how do i take
hmm I wonder a chick with the pawn
taking with the rook I have Queen h7
coming pretty quickly yeah I think this
looks tempting to have this possibility
now I can go Queen h7 immediately not
sure how dangerous this actually is but
it's something to think about when like
age 6 UC going queen to F age maybe
sorry to d8 it and and then to come over
here yeah he played that and okay so i
think Bishop f4 is in order Quinn g8
maybe anyway I have to get rid of the
special
yeah quick win g8 is probably not a bad
idea of them okay I don't want to treat
Queen Sam ok and now on castles long for
Luke to g1 maybe Queen h7 something
interesting and then I take then I take
yeah it would be self in a little bit
what is the general idea here maybe
taking on d6 and plain night to g3 yep
that could be good getting rid of you
turns into the self-penned that's
surprising it's got queen age 6 uh-huh
ok I do that anyway it's okay with the
night and no I thought not g3 but he has
he has to check on age 6 so mmm and this
is hanging so i can actually check me
come on so i have to maybe cover this
first
now g3 is still as the check if I go to
your here is not to check anymore and
it's still the cell depends on sonai g3
wood oak h8 does he want to play this
ending maybe what about night f form
night f4 here and then potentially if i
go here queen age 6 i can take on e6 so
that doesn't work that maybe threatening
look you wanna just to attack this yeah
that looks quite good at least it's my
initial impression if he goes to h eight
year i also have 96 as an idea after
Luke age 8 covering if you covers the
Queen you might move the night to for
the trade so this is something that is
important
okay in any rookie one in my debt this
is this was kind of clear so here you
can sec the queer we cannot sec the
Queen ok let's go that and now see what
what am I doing here I don't have much
time breaking in yeah I move the rookie
will take it maybe I get get out of this
and now we place here I'm still covering
everything you hear the queen is
somewhat imprisoned 96 to you for
something I know I actually didn't see
97 I have to react to this knowledge
it's not even a good move I can just
take it I just assumed you would go to
d6 time yeah that that's very stupid ah
I never expected 97 to happen I can just
take a nun better I just thought you
place 96 ok so you get a pawn give the
tongue it's very very stupid stuff just
have to see what you plays and react
accordingly don't don't ever assume they
play a good move whoa whatever i'm not
sure if 96 feels good well 97 I can I
just take so
so maybe I get some counter play here
Brooks is seven ok time catching up one
of the time a little bit ok screen age
five he has ok how do look back the rook
back no no but that was that was still
what I should do just put the Rope back
to see 10 gauge to now looks dangerous
whoa how does he stop that I don't think
he can ha that was lucky Black Rose I I
am still upset yeah that I just assumed
he plays 96 because that would make
perfect sense that you try to go to e
497 I just take and I'm better I mean
but I basically it was almost like a pre
move him I was just assuming he goes to
d6 damn I mean you can feel like you can
get the engine view engine wants to play
a queen age 7 and gives me a small
actually I was thinking it's probably
equal I mean it's a weird position but I
was thinking is equal and here I just
taken I'm better of course yeah after
the trade of the night so I must be
better i have a group g1 i have things
that i can attack and he's not easily
coordinating this or the engine on to
play g5 if that's necessary he's really
in bad shape I was just assuming
automatically he would play night d6 and
I wanted to go here and then play like
this try to invade with the Queen here
this is kind of
protecting its protecting each other in
a way and then my queen can can try to
enter there it was my idea anyway let's
let's go back a little bit and see how
this unfolded and this is roughly
theoretical I think this is kind of
thing 23 I'm not sure about this but i
think i have to take now i think this is
a well-known blunder so i took it he
took with the rook yeah this this held
logical to me and give him jack while
try try to make him trade and all night
air force is possible engine says equal
roughly equal am I think um if Y places
really well you should have an advantage
but I don't know the exact path to that
okay here C 3 and this felt quite
logical route k except so that I can
enter probably the Equality was never
really disturbed yet this was
interesting huh I was actually thinking
he can go g6 but maybe that's not the
case even though the engine doesn't give
anything great here yeah i was a little
bit concerned that the point is not
promote and if he gets lost
oh sorry let's get rid of this if you
can go look like here that if I this
this could be week actually could be a
week porn ok so this look to also be too
tempting yeah I wanted to get rid of the
bishop my bishop looks like a bad piece
o which rated this let that felt like
completely reasonable I think oops nope
asics I could have checked me there
already 410 the engine thinks I'm better
with a 3 here or weekly one ok so this
wasn't that great probably it still
gives me an edge because I can return a
three-year ok
one mukhi won the rookie wanna
understand a little bit more than a
three Tim dad I mean I was just thinking
along the lines if he moves the night
and have to trade but ok is 6am hanging
them so this and then it wants to go
back yeah if anybody white is probably
better him the engine is in the position
that that is so concrete the engine is
normally I played perfectly so its own
and there's not it doesn't look like
there's some some some depth problem or
something so I believe that the
advantage that it gives for widest
probably were probably true the ante ok
he was this thing I was just expecting
96 to happen so I played yet I'm
plundering the the poor now and i'm just
a poor down it's not super easy maybe to
win for black this was probably wrong a
[ __ ] a test the engine indicated but
yeah it's not all that easy for him to a
queen you for it's actually easier than
i have to go back yeah i know this this
looks like i'm getting some chances cha
yeah yes it's already a draw now or not
yeah maybe it's a draw yeah but not
anymore after that I think if you tried
a little bit too hard ready to win that
that's what you always does it gives
them many points also but sometimes she
loses positions that yeah I'm ver draw
is right or if you're a little bit more
conservative maybe but ok it's blitz
chess so it tries to set problems and
sometimes it's it just dumb yeah blows
up in your own face ok guys thanks for
watching